in the world of professional wrestling
there's something called a swerve some
examples these tag team partners are
called baby faces or the good guys then
one of them swerves when he super kicks
his tag team partner in the head quickly
assuming the role of the bad guy or what
the wrestling world calls the heel where
match is almost lost when that's that
the superstar wrestler appears out of
nowhere sprinting down the aisle to save
the match
[Applause]
that's ass worth so it should go is no
surprise that World Wrestling
Entertainment known as the WWE the most
popular brand of sports entertainment in
the world is prepared for any swerves
that come their way
so here's the story of how the WWE learn
to see the swear of coming so I spoke to
Bloomberg reporters Felix Gillette I'm a
writer for Bloomberg News for the global
business team in Kimba seen and I'm the
us luxury reporter at Bloomberg to find
out exactly how the WWE is positioning
itself for an all-out global invasion
which starts with a massive change to
their lucrative pay-per-view model W
basically pioneers the pay-per-view
model on cable I remember as a kid when
the pay-per-view events came up all of
our friends would scramble around and
try and get one of the parents to pay
for it but in 2014 they took a huge risk
they saw a little bit sooner than some
of the other entertainment brands that
we're this whole thing was moving was
away from cable and satellite television
and towards on-demand streaming video
apps they made this risky decision in
essence cannibalizing that pay-per-view
model which they had essentially built
and after some early turbulence it's
working roughly 1.5 million people are
paying $9.99 a month for the WWE app
making it the fifth most popular
streaming OTT service
this adapter dye approach is in the
WWE's DNA over the past thirty years the
company always seems to think two steps
ahead in the early 90s
WWE was at its most threatened when Ted
Turner took them on with WCW which
stands for World Championship Wrestling
and back then the WCW was winning the
ratings war so in order to compete with
them WWE had changed its product from a
family-friendly kind of cart
style is really raw that's why they
called their show raw it was this raw
style of wrestling with violent
outrageous reality inspired plot lines
and aggressive personas and they won
that fight against Ted Turner and they
buck WCW the early 2000s assured in an
era of testosterone driven programming
aimed at the red-blooded American man
and until 2015 when WWE fans started a
hashtag give divas a chance since then
WWE has hired 40 more female wrestlers
and that growing cast of female
characters was part of a much larger
plan they started to try to appeal to a
broader set of people
let's attract more female fans and after
we've attract more female fans let's
attract more international fans they're
broadening their base and they're doing
that in large part to make it more
advertising friendly and not just
friendly to advertisers they're trying
to build up their fan base in China
they're trying to build up their fan
base in Europe there you know already
have a pretty good fan base in India
India as a place where they already have
an established wrestling culture because
of the gigantic Indian wrestler the
Great Khali
but there's still a lot of work to do
while the WWE set a revenue record in
2017 only 30 percent of it is coming
from an overseas audience and there's
one person whose responsibility is to
grow that number the buck eventually
stops at Vince McMahon no matter what's
happening within WWE yeah he's a very
controlling guy and that's a very very
very tightly scripted company and that
goes all the way down the board to big
stars entrance music
in there their outfits and things like
that so with the CEO like McMahon always
planning to moves ahead and an
aggressive push into multiple
international markets a big issue is
money it's hard to do all those things
simultaneously without committing the
huge amount of capital to it and that's
where the WWE becomes an attractive
company for buyers potentially one thing
that could happen with WWE is they could
benefit by being acquired by a bigger
technology or telecom company an Amazon
or Facebook or a 21st Century Fox so
with a market cap of 2.8 billion dollars
the advantage of owning 100% of their
own content and a rapid consolidation
spreading throughout the entertainment
industry it looks like the WWE is
well-positioned even if there are
swerves ahead
you